bonjour à toutes et à tous les invités
de giorgio armani espérer voir défiler
quelques unes des plus belles filles du
monde hier soir à paris à la place on
leur a envoyé deux grands crs moustachu
habillée tout en bleue le défilé du
couturier italien qui devait se tenir
sous un chapiteau place saint sulpice à
saint germain des prés a été annulée au
dernier moment pour raisons de sécurité
nicole cornu angloys hervé powder 21h
place saint sulpice mille invités
arrivent pour un événement dans le monde
de la mode le premier défilé
prêt-à-porter de giorgio armani à paris
des menaces planaient concernant les
autorisations problèmes de sécurité le
couturier a donc essayé d'apporter des
modifications d'urgence mission
impossible
le défilé a été interpellé quatre mois
de travail le gardeur on va dire qu'on
peut pas possible la nouvelle a réjoui
les écologistes et les riverains qui
s'étaient opposés à cette manifestation
les laisser au public
donc nous refusons nous écologistes que
les places de ligue de paris soit
accaparé par des manifestations privées
au moment où paris se bat pour garder la
suprématie sur new york et milan pour la
mode cet incident a provoqué de vives
réactions un camouflet c'est un coup bas
et je trouve que tous les couturiers
parisiens sont son giflé et insulté par
ce procédé les 45 minutes avant un
défilé où tout le monde est venu parce
que c'est le meilleur c'est tout à fait
anormal c'est scandaleux
cette bataille d'armani n'est pas
nouvelle à paris pour le couturiers
milanais en installant sa boutique place
saint-germain-des-prés il avait déjà
soulevé de violentes polémiques
bonne nouvelle tout de même jacques
mouclier président de la fédération de
la couture lui offre ce soir une salle
gratuite pour défiler au carrousel du
louvre